if somebody was coming to atlanta and
they'd never been to a strip club what
would be the one place you'd be like you
got to go here probably taking a major
city i went to magic city i was
disappointed did i eat the wings they
weren't good
they were all right
were you there cook
i was very disappointed they were tiny
ass wings bro
you know that magic city once you want
the jumbo wings bro you know that magic
city wings are small as hell you want
the jumbo wings are they not small ass
wings depends on what night man you i
winged this a weenie size bro i heard
the blue flame is is better food wise
maybe i don't know guess what killer
mike told me no
no i'm going i ain't going i ain't going
but
he's going to say yeah he's going to hit
up the flag
all right let's see if we talking about
food hey [ __ ] cheetah is a five-star
restaurant and that's like a they play
like nickel back in there right i don't
know what they play yeah they do yeah
yeah that means i can ask you look at
this
yo jaren benton tried to take me to the
claremont lounge oh yeah that's like a
real scum little freak show you said
there was midgets and elderly women in
there bro one arm one one leg ladies and
[ __ ] that's nice you've been in there
yeah i mean that comes off yeah he was
like yo i'm gonna take you to this place
bro it's crazy
[ __ ] old women in one arm
yeah man midgets
all kinds of [ __ ] it's one of them
i could imagine like that [ __ ] being in
like tijuana or some [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying like just a just a random
night just drive down there and just
like you ever been to tj no man we plan
on going soon man i got a homie in san
diego go to san diego check out tj they
got great mexican food great mexican
food yeah man
yeah they got the tacos every corner the
bed the best tacos